[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com we did have some primaries
yesterday I was following some races
more closely than others I was very
interested in the gubernatorial primary
in California where Democrat Gavin
Newsom and Republican John Cox have
advanced Gavin Newsom of course former
San Francisco mayor I recall correctly
right am I missing I don't know in San
Francisco mayor and that is a very
interesting race big picture you know I
I mentioned this on the regular show Pat
I am concerned a bit about Democratic
turnout in the midterm elections which
if there is really going to be an
opportunity to stop the Trump insanity
its people voting in November and I am
NOT particularly inspired by yesterday's
results it's a little hard to say
because of course this is just the
primary it's not the general election
yeah but it seems like a lot of the
incumbents did move on and win their
respective primaries big names out there
like Adam Schiff and Devon Nunez Dana
Rohrabacher all out of California sure
and Dianne Feinstein in the Senate
primary she advances to face either
I think Kevin de Lyonne or the
Republican there so that's a little bit
disappointing because Feinstein is known
as one of these corporate Democrats
someone who is in support of the death
penalty has never seen a war she didn't
like and you know is has been serving
for a long time so you think that there
would might be a chance to get her out
of office I guess we'll have to see you
November yeah there was actually a big
activism happening in California I think
that Jenk and justice Democrats had a
candidate they've got running against
her Allison some thousand hearts and man
I I I don't even know if I should really
tell this story but the conference I
went to and in that I go to in Vegas
every too much - year every six months
twice a year I went in April and she was
actually Jenk came with her to speak at
the lunch on one of the conference days
I was not impressed
I really wasn't and I I have not gotten
involved in that race in any way and I
just much like you I'm not a big Diane
fine
ix fan but as soon as I saw her speak I
immediately knew and I knew maybe she
was all like maybe I just needed to look
at polls to know she wasn't gonna win
but I immediately knew she wasn't gonna
win and it sort of disappointing but I
was very underwhelmed with her both the
young turks and kyle kolinsky did a lot
of segments about her because Alison
Hartson ran or currently runs wolf pack
which I think's political action
community committee which is aimed at
getting money out of politics right and
she's also a justice Democrat but I
looked at the results yesterday it
wasn't even close she came in ninth
place and got shot or not was in place I
figured she would come in second or
third just based on genk getting
involved you know but that's not that's
not good not probably ninth is ninth is
not good yeah so listen I think that now
is what by the way one thing we are
doing is I've explained before that in
general candidate interviews our
audience just doesn't like them right
and when we get pitched a candidate
interview before the primary we have to
be really careful because of equal time
laws if we interview one pre primary
candidate we legally speaking because
we're on broadcast radio and television
we do have to offer equal time to
anybody else who wants it and in the
primaries like for example that
California primary there might have been
eight people who wanted it Dianne
Feinstein probably would not appear on
the program but those eight other
challengers on the Democratic side might
have and we can't turn two or three
weeks of the show into just interviewing
California Senate Democratic candidates
right as we start to get past the
primaries and a lot of the primaries
were yesterday we now can start doing
some interviews of progressive Democrats
that are running because the worst thing
that would happen because of equal time
laws is that maybe a Democrat Republican
incumbent wants time and that would be
fine with us
yeah I think that would be fine do you
have any names in mind some progressive
Democrats running across the country who
may want to come on the show no
absolutely none whatsoever
yeah no you know I'm kidding but we have
some people that were thinking about
having on but I mean I was speaking more
theoretically about don't I wanted to
call me on silence speak for itself I
didn't want to jump in there and save
you yes
Miss America is getting rid of its
swimsuit competition and it is no longer
going to judge contestants based on
physical appearance according to an
announcement made yesterday gretchen
carlson who is a former Miss America
former Hawk Fox News anchor she is the
chair of the board of trustees of the
Miss America Organization and she said
we are no longer a pageant we are a
competition which of course immediately
raises the question what are you going
to compete on if not your physical
appearance and this is actually even
among sort of uh what it would I need to
pick my words carefully here
even among egalitarian and enlightened
leftists there are some elements of
confusion as to well does it become a
spelling bee do you do a standardized
test like a GMAT like what how what is
the competition you know what I mean
well they had like the talent portion of
the show for some time yes I think it
was obvious to everyone that it really
just came to body shape and
attractiveness yeah and even the talent
part it's like so are you saying what
what what is it that you're making it
right like if you make it a writing
competition then it's closer to a
spelling bee than to anything that you
would call Miss America if it's a focus
on the talent part it's kind of like the
reality show America's Got Talent or
x-factor or one of those shows right so
the what they're saying is they're going
to be demonstrating their passion
intelligence and understanding of the
job of Miss America as part of the
competition I think this is fine like
quite frankly I never watched it before
when physical appearance was what was
being evaluated and I'm still not going
to watch it now I'm just kind of
confused by the entire thing and some
sort of genuine and honest way yeah I
don't think we still have to have the
pageant at all I mean we can start
phasing it out and you know if it
becomes some intellectual competition
that would be an interesting change I
think I wonder if you know the the
winner this year will be attractive
based on you know society's normal
expectations of what beauty is sure
that'll be interesting to see but yeah I
don't I don't
also I wonder if it's going to devolve
into some set
like spelling bee or like an aptitude
test and I feel like you know in decades
past this peak it was a lot more like
interesting to people to watch
especially like truck might show up hey
yeah I mean ever show up in the changing
room but like I think you know man at
that time had very few opportunities to
see women not wearing too much clothing
oh you can see like Miss America beauty
pageant or they could see the Sports
Illustrated swimsuit edition sure and
that was about it
but now because of the internet even men
who want to see that kind of stuff
aren't tuning in to Miss America excuse
me if I may Pat is going out of his way
to use very very vague language Pat's
saying now that online porn exists why
do you need any kind of element of
beauty in Miss America is that Pat K if
I translated thank you for the
translation yes I was trying to
wordsmith
and be careful like you were earlier on
in a segment yeah but it didn't go so
well I know a few so this might surprise
people but there's sort of a you know
you've heard of the school to Prison
Pipeline
there is a pageant to newswoman pipeline
that also exists and I know three
different former pageant people women
who have moved on to working in the news
media and I follow some of them on
different online platforms and they
yesterday when this news broke were
genuinely upset saying that they
believed that the physical evaluation
was really an example of female
empowerment because knowing you were
going to be evaluated for your body
allowed you to basically take control
and say I decide how in shape I am I'm
trying to get through this all with a
completely straight face because I don't
totally buy into it
I decide how fit I am and it is my
opportunity as a woman to say here is
what I am capable of in terms of how fit
I'm going to be and that then there are
it is a meritocracy because you are
evaluated on what you achieve in terms
of your looks and fitness and
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba okay I mean I don't know
does that does that even make sense to
you I guess I sort of see it but at the
same time when a lot of what's being
done is like unhealthy star
of oneself I don't know that it's
actually something that we should be
cheering you know yeah it's like a Miss
America see you could say do you ever
see the John Oliver piece exposing Miss
America now because they claim to be the
largest provider of scholarships for
women in the entire country
no no then when you dig into it they're
offering scholarships to like three
schools and apparently like very few
people actually take them up on the
offer
oh and so instead of you know offering
whatever it is like fifty million
dollars it turns out they offer a
hundred thousand when you take a look at
it well that's similar to the Walmart
story we did where they're now going to
be offering schooling for that the
employee pays just a dollar a day they
pay for the rest but you have to go to
one of three online schools yeah I don't
know I mean it's something but is it
exactly what it's is it equivalent to
the PR benefit that they gain from it I
guess is sort of the question
hey David hog has been swatted he is one
of the students from Marjory Stoneman
Douglas High School in parkland Florida
which was the site of this horrific mass
shooting not long ago and he's become a
prominent gun safety activist he was
swatted yesterday morning for people who
don't know what this is swatting is
something that became popular I guess I
would say like in the online in the
online world I don't even know how else
to say and the idea is that if someone
is maybe doing a live stream you call up
and say that they're holding hostages or
say whatever it you think you need to
say to get the SWAT team to break down
their door while the person is
live-streaming and then you know it's
crazy the person gets arrested
ultimately it's determined that there
wasn't actually really a threat and and
you know the person is released but
oftentimes their place is destroyed and
they're incredibly traumatized because
SWAT broke literally broke down the door
while they were doing a live stream this
happened to david hog there were people
who were they've made it so that
emergency services and and SWAT showed
up at david hogs home and it's illegal
but it often doesn't lead to
consequences because the people doing it
know how to sort of shield their
identity and it's it's absolutely a
horrible thing to do isn't it
interesting though that the SWAT team
didn't take a closer look at this before
acting upon it because honest
David hog has become a pretty household
name yes actually this is Florida right
so you know if I was working there my
first instinct was that this is just
being done as a hit piece by some
conservative or some pro-gun fanatic I
get what you're saying closer look for
sure think for a second though if you're
just a 900 and you get a call about
David hog are you gonna risk ignoring
protocol by saying I don't know I'm not
actually gonna send emergency services
right away because I recognize you're
not gonna take that risk right like I
understand why the operator who gets the
call does what they what protocol
dictates well I mean like you know maybe
a police officer showing up at the door
seeing what's going on would be okay but
a SWAT team you know six seven guys
barging down the door and storming the
place to find nothing going on there and
no one home I mean I think that could
have been avoided I wish that it would
have been avoided because this is
absolutely horrible and I think that
when we read about these stories it's
very easy to say oh yeah that's horrible
imagine actually being on the receiving
end of it and the level of trauma and
and PTSD that this could cause right
like imagine if when I'm doing one of my
live streams on YouTube next thing that
happens is I hear you know my door
broken down and potentially a flashbang
is thrown in
during my street like it's not even
conceivable like I understand the
horrifying nature of it and how this is
just a terrible thing to do but this is
a hugely traumatic thing to have happen
and I think that it's hard to really put
yourself in that position unless it
happens yeah do you think David hog is
handling his newfound celebrity in the
direction of his activism well because
he was thrown into the public spotlight
in a sense you know this tragedy
happened at the school he attended and
he made the decision to continue going
on these new shows and to speak his mind
but you know it's questionable the kids
only 17 18 years old yep and you know
your mind isn't fully formed yet you're
going out in the world and subjects all
this criticism you know I don't know if
I would want to be in that position if
fully formed minds were necessary to do
regular media appearances the TV news
industry would be in
ideally decimated so I don't think we
can hold him to that standard I think
that he's doing a good thing I do
believe that there have been some
missteps and how he handled maybe
particular you know tweets or whatever
but again we're talking about a kid here
so yeah I think big picture you know I'm
supportive of what he's doing doesn't
mean I agree with every tactic that he
has employed but I think he's handling
it pretty well and listen he's very
mature for I don't know how old he is 17
or 18 years old he's actually quite
mature I don't think he comes off as
like a little kid in any way yeah I
think he said something like dana loesch
has the blood of kids on her hands or
something yeah pretty egregious but you
know when I think back to when I was
that long though I mean she's not
directly responsible for anything I
think that's a step too far you know but
she you know he's putting himself out of
the public out in the public spotlight
so if he wants to debate gun policy he
also has to be able to take the
criticism he can't hide behind his age
you know you can't have it both ways
you if you can't stand the heat you've
got to get out of the kitchen or people
in glass houses shouldn't throw stones
or what if it's another one of these I
don't know insert whichever one of the
bottles is luck calling the kettle black
yeah well that's more of a hypocrisy
thing but yeah if you can't you got to
be able to take it if you're going to
dish it or something like that but very
very horrible situation for David Cobb
that's it for today's bonus show we'll
talk to you tomorrow
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]